Let's follow along as the
assembler processes our source
file.
The assembler maintains
a symbol table
that maps symbols names
to their numeric values.
Initially the symbol table
is loaded with mappings
for all the register symbols.
The assembler reads the
source file line-by-line,
defining symbols and labels,
expanding macros, or evaluating
expressions to generate
bytes for the output array.
Whenever the assembler
encounters a use of a symbol
or label, it's replaced by the
corresponding numeric value
found in the symbol table.
The first line, N = 12, defines
the value of the symbol N
to be 12, so the
appropriate entry
is made in the symbol table.
Advancing to the next
line, the assembler
encounters an invocation
of the ADDC macro
with the arguments
"r31", "N", and "r1".
As we'll see in a
couple of slides,
this triggers a series of
nested macro expansions
that eventually lead to
generating a 32-bit binary
value to be placed
in memory location 0.
The 32-bit value
is formatted here
to show the instruction fields
and the destination address
is shown in brackets.
The next instruction is
processed in the same way,
generating a second 32-bit word.
On the fourth line,
the label loop
is defined to have the value
of the location in memory
that's about to filled,
in this case, location 8.
So the appropriate entry
is made in the symbol table
and the MUL macro is
expanded into the 32-bit word
to be placed in location 8.
The assembler processes
the file line-by-line
until it reaches
the end of the file.
Actually the assembler makes
two passes through the file.
On the first pass it loads the
symbol table with the values
from all the symbol
and label definitions.
Then, on the second pass, it
generates the binary output.
The two-pass approach
allows a statement
to refer to symbol or
label that is defined later
in the file, e.g., a
forward branch instruction
could refer to the
label for an instruction
later in the program.
As we saw in the
previous slide, there's
nothing magic about
the register symbols.
They are just symbolic names
for the values 0 through 31.
So when processing
ADDC(r31,N,r1),
UASM replaces the symbols
with their values and actually
expands ADDC(31,12,1).
UASM is very simple.
It simply replaces
symbols with their values,
expands macros and
evaluates expressions.
So if you use a register
symbol where a numeric value is
expected, the
value of the symbol
is used as the numeric constant.
Probably not what the
programmer intended.
Similarly, if you use a symbol
or expression where a register
number is expected, the
low-order 5 bits of the value
is used as the register
number, in this example,
as the Rb register number.
Again probably not what
the programmer intended.
The moral of the story is that
when writing UASM assembly
language programs, you have
to keep your wits about you
and recognize that the
interpretation of an operand
is determined by the opcode
macro, not by the way
you wrote the operand.
Recall from Lecture 9
that branch instructions
use the 16-bit constant
field of the instruction
to encode the address
of the branch target
as a word offset from the
location of the branch
instruction.
Well, actually the offset is
calculated from the instruction
immediately following the
branch, so an offset of -1
would refer to
the branch itself.
The calculation of the offset
is a bit tedious to do by hand
and would, of course, change
if we added or removed
instructions between the branch
instruction and branch target.
Happily macros for the
branch instructions
incorporate the
necessary formula
to compute the offset from
the address of the branch
and the address of
the branch target.
So we just specify the
address of the branch target,
usually with a label, and let
UASM do the heavy lifting.
Here we see that BNE branches
backwards by three instructions
(remember to count from
the instruction following
the branch) so the offset is -3.
The 16-bit two's complement
representation of -3
is the value placed in the
constant field of the BNE
All the macro definitions for the Beta ISA
are provided in the beta.uasm file, which
is included in each of the assembly language
lab assignments.
Note that we include some convenience macros
to define shorthand representations that provide
common default values for certain operands.
For example, except for procedure calls, we
don't care about the PC+4 value saved in the
destination register by branch instructions,
so almost always would specify R31 as the
Rc register, effectively discarding the PC+4
value saved by branches.
So we define two-argument branch macros that
automatically provide R31 as the destination
register.
Saves some typing, and, more importantly,
it makes it easier to understand the assembly
language program.
Here are a whole set of convenience macros
intended to make programs more readable.
For example, unconditional branches can be
written using the BR() macro rather than the
more cumbersome BEQ(R31,...).
And it's more readable to use branch-false
(BF) and branch-true (BT) macros when testing
the results of a compare instruction.
And note the PUSH and POP macros at the bottom
of page.
These expand into multi-instruction sequences,
in this case to add and remove values from
a stack data structure pointed to by the SP
register.
We call these macros "pseudo instructions"
since they let us provide the programmer with
what appears a larger instruction set,
although underneath the covers we've just
using the same small instruction repertoire
developed in Lecture 9.
In this example we've rewritten the original
code we had for the factorial computation
using pseudo instructions.
For example, CMOVE is a pseudo instruction
for moving small constants into a register.
It's easier for us to read and understand
the intent of a "constant move" operation
than an "add a value to 0" operation provided
by the ADDC expansion of CMOVE.
Anything we can do to remove the cognitive
clutter will be very beneficial in the long
run.